the United States has slowed the spread
of coronavirus but there's one scourge
whose virality is only increasing fake
news we will examine the most egregious
examples of how the left-wing media lies
to add panic to the pandemic then in an
effort to combat kovat a democratic
mayor politely asks criminals to chill
and a New York Jail releases a bunch of
child molesters meanwhile prosperity
preachers command the virus to go away
and president Trump rains fire and
brimstone down on Jim Acosta during his
latest ratings busting press briefing
all that and so much more I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]
we caught them in the act we caught
those fake news media spreading more
fake news about the corona virus we will
air one example in particular that would
be shocking and unprecedented if we
didn't just see it like six months ago
we'll get to that in one second first
I've got to thank our friends over at
rain you know it is especially around
this time very important to know who's
knocking on your door who's trying to
get into your home ring gives you
protection at every corner and helps you
create custom affordable security for
your home ring detects motion when
people come onto your property and rings
video doorbells lets you answer the door
and check in on your home anytime from
anywhere you know the other day we get a
little knock on our door we can check to
see who it is oh it's just our lovely
neighbor asking if he can borrow some
tea okay that's that's very nice
sometimes it's a burglar maybe you don't
want to answer the door then sometimes
it's your mother-in-law then you
definitely don't want to answer the door
you need a ring especially now you know
especially when I'm on when I'm on the
road a lot sweet little lease is a very
good shot so she can take care of
herself but I like to feel safe you can
get peace of mind knowing that your
loved ones are safe get a special offer
on the Ring welcome kit when you go to
ring.com slash knowles came to wles that
includes the ring video doorbell
two-inch i'm pro it's all you need to
start building custom security for your
home today go to ring comm slash knowles
that is ring comm slash knowles came to
wles this is the worst fake news that I
have seen on network television in I
guess about six months but you know
listen that's a lot because there's a
whole lot of fake news going through CBS
News is trying to whip people up into a
frenzy and hysteria about coronavirus
generally and specifically the situation
in New York so they decided to air
footage showing the madness of a
hospital in New York now coronavirus
serious problem in New York it's much
more serious there than I guess anywhere
else in the United States so why do the
TV networks why did the mainstream news
media
feel the need to lie to make it seem
even worse than it is CBS News aired
footage of an overcrowded hospital room
in New York City that actually wasn't in
New York City it actually wasn't in the
United States it actually wasn't in the
Western Hemisphere
it was in Italy it was an editing
mistake
they say they took immediate steps to
remove it from all platforms and shows
here is the footage side by side you
will hear the report from British news
talking about this hospital room in
Italy and if you can see it you'll be
able to see that it is almost
shot-for-shot the same room that they're
pretending is in New York this is the
main hospital in Bergamo in long-bodied
province it's one of the most advanced
there it is you can see it's the exact
same room and they're pretending that
this is in New York this is not the
first time we've seen this do you
remember I think it was about six months
ago when ABC News made a similar mistake
by airing footage that they said was the
situation in Syria with Turkish gunfire
raining down on the poor Kurds and this
was all Trump's fault and he betrayed
our allies and it just looked like a
scene out of an apocalyptic movie and
then it turned out actually it wasn't in
Syria actually it wasn't in the Middle
East actually it wasn't this year it was
from a Kentucky gun show in 2017 you'll
right here a period of show turkeys
military bombing Kurd civilians in a
Syrian border town this video obtained
by ABC News appears to show the fury of
the Turkish attack on the border town of
Talib yet two nights ago and it appears
to show the attack on the border town
because we've decided to overlay this
voiceover actually though it's from a
Kentucky gun show and if we told you it
was a Kentucky gun show you would have
believed that too you'll believe
whatever we tell you where the news
media outrageous stuff obviously this is
why people no longer really believe the
mainstream media but they continue to do
it why do they continue to do it because
nobody sees the correction nobody saw
nobody unless you're watching this show
listening to this show reading some
conservative news outlets you would not
know that CBS News actually was airing
footage of crowded hospital rooms in
Italy which is much worse off than the
United States you would not know that
unless you are watching or listening to
conservative media you would have no
idea that that footage that was supposed
to be from battlefields you know Turkey
rolling the tanks in was actually from a
Kentucky gun show because what happened
in the case of the the Kentucky gun show
ABC News admits on Twitter that you know
this was wrong they issue a correction
but the original news story gets orders
of magnitude more retweets and likes
than the correction the original
news story gets seen on the biggest TV
shows on ABC the correction gets seen as
post number 25 of the day on Twitter
nobody sees the correction this is how
they get away with it so the newspapers
have gotten away with it for years you
know they run the fake story on page a1
and then they run the correction in tiny
print on pages Z 75 so that's the
mainstream media this is also true on
social media we don't want to let
Twitter get off the hook here either
Laura Ingraham a little while ago sent
out a tweet when it looked like we had
this promising new drug to treat
coronavirus hydroxychloroquine Laura
Ingraham tweets at Lennox Hill in New
York among many hospitals already using
hydroxychloroquine with very promising
results one patient was described as
Lazarus who was seriously ill from covin
19 already released
what did Twitter do Twitter suspended
her account for that you're not allowed
to say that there's light at the end of
the tunnel you're not allowed to say
that there might be some hope among this
pandemic dammit the media is trying to
whip up a panic and Laura Ingram's
getting in their way by suggesting that
we might have a decent medical treatment
for it so they suspend her account they
tell her that she's got to delete the
tweet if she wants to get her account
back they said it was quote misleading
information around Co vid 19 and then
guess what happened yesterday the FDA
approved the drug to treat coronavirus
guess it wasn't fake news after all
doesn't matter the tweets gone the
story's at they're fake news Laura
engrams gotta delete her tweet now you
know the federal government has forced
Twitter's hand because the FDA has
approved this drug but why on earth
would Twitter not take the more cautious
position why would Twitter not say well
look some evidence shows that
hydroxychloroquine is working to treat
coronavirus but we don't have long
clinical trials yet so okay we'll just
let the information stand out there your
mileage may vary judge for yourself no
because they are pushing a narrative
here the narrative is panic the
narrative is the world is ending the
narrative is ultimately what they won
their specific political role is Donald
Trump is doing a
terrible job he's bundling this he's
he's killing people that's the as the
ultimate narrative here and so Twitter
is always gonna air on that side ABC
news always gonna air on that side we
don't know where this footage is we just
like found this in the street someone
just okay let's just assume it's
evidence that Trump did made a terrible
move in the Middle East oh it's a
Kentucky gun show whoopsie-daisy no big
deal oh yeah we got this footage of a
hospital room yeah it looks like New
York yeah it Trump's a bad guy yeah
where is it terrible yeah we're all
gonna die you could have you could have
googled it right you could have looked
around you could've said wait why are
they all speaking Italian and I know
there are a lot of Italians in New York
but I don't think there were that many
Italians we got another bit of fake news
yesterday too this has to do with a
hospital ship and this one came by way
of my doppelganger Rachel Maddow on
MSNBC we we've got the footage of it
President Trump actually just released
it just an absolute joy we'll get to it
in a second first I've got to thank our
friends the Benham brothers do you know
the venom brothers I know the venom
brothers and they are terrific guys the
first of all fabulous personalities in
general former pro athletes I mean just
super cool and they know a lot about
building a business what's the secret
do you know you'll probably say you got
a hustle till you die you got to
probably think so you've gotta get
success no matter the cost
it doesn't have to be that way you can
grow business without sacrificing your
family and character that's where the
venom brothers come in they they have
over a dozen businesses including a real
estate empire that spans over 35 states
and they didn't sell their soul for it
you probably remember the name actually
because the Benham brothers were slated
for a reality TV show on HGTV and they
were cancelled because of their
commitment to conservative values they
were OG victims of canceled culture
they're really terrific they launched
their wonderful expert ownership course
it's the model they've used to build
each one of their businesses whether
you're sick of the 9 to 5 or you have a
10 year old business expert ownership
can help you achieve your goals
especially these days a lot of people
trying to get their businesses back on
track right now you get 15% off for new
members you can check out a preview of
the course and take advantage of that
discount over at
Menem brothers dot-com / Knowles kayo
wles
that's benh am benh am brothers calm /
Knowles Kanna wles head on over there to
check out the course alright so my
doppelganger over on MSNBC ran a story
about this hospital ship that the
federal government was sending to New
York to take care of people and deal
with the overflow from coronavirus
President Trump just released the clip
but he added a little negative buzzer a
little wrong answer buzzer every time
she told fake news compare that story on
MSNBC with the reality of what actually
happened in terms of the happy talk
we've had on this front from the federal
government there is no song that the
navy hospital ships that the president
made such a big deal of a comfort in the
mercy there's nothing that there'll be
anywhere on sight helping out anywhere
in the country for weeks the president
said when he announced that those ships
would be put into action against the
cove in nineteen epidemic he said one of
those ships would be operational in New
York Harbor by next week it's nonsense
it will not be there next the comfort
has arrived in New York and is now
making its way up the river I'm on the
west side right around Houston Street
not far from where we work and it's
being led in a parade of tugs and Coast
Guard vessels helicopters circling above
Navy hospital ship mercy is now docked
at the port of LA it will serve as an
overflow facility for patients who don't
have kovat 19 CBS 2's car finnstrom is
live in san pedro with a look at the
arrival and what's to come kara
Susanna's massive ship represents hope
support for overwhelmed medical workers
and I have to say as it came in it was
great to see the smiles on faces here on
the shore the excitement take a look it
just represents hope and it just really
represents the refreshing meadow is
completely wrong about this my question
for Maddow is and not just Matt I mean
to just single out my my doppelganger my
question for all of these people in the
fake news media they end up looking so
ridiculous why not just wait Trump says
we're gonna send this hospital ship why
get out ahead of that and say no you
won't you know you won't do that I mean
they do this all the time Trump says I'm
gonna get tax cuts no you won't you're
not gonna get that through Trump says
I'm gonna be vindicated by the Muller
probe know you would smaller time you're
going down try again and again they just
they keep making these predictions and
the predictions are not true and then
they have egg on their face that's the
question for a reasonable viewer but I
guess there is an answer to it which is
that their viewers are not checking up
on this stuff not just Maddow but the
network news viewers and the New York
Times readers and people who consume the
mainstream media apparatus they don't
need to be as precise they don't need to
be as careful because they are the
dominant media force so sure so we'll
point it out you know if you if you
listen to my show you'll hear where they
go wrong but compared to the audience of
all of network television forget even
cable forget even all these
subscriptions just regular network
television that's the dumb and an
audience and so they can get away with
it the news is fake all right I never
want to hear again that fake news is a
right-wing conspiracy or a talking point
the news is fake even when they get
stories right they themselves are
peddlers of fake narratives so even a
stop clock is Right twice a day we've
known that for a long time what's worse
now is that it would appear that even
their models are fake too
let me give you a great example there
was a a good piece just published in
medium I'm sure they're gonna delete
as soon because it questions the
official narrative on everybody
panicking this is by Maria chiquinha and
Wesley Pegg Dhin leave there to two
mathematicians so they were looking at
just the models but they're not looking
at the specific biology or the you know
chemical characteristics of the virus
they're just looking at the models that
all of us are talking about and the
models that led us to shut down the
global economy and the title is a call
to honesty in pandemic modeling they use
a number of examples but but here's just
one so nicholas kristof a writer for The
New York Times decides to publish a
model by a group of researchers and the
the point of this model shows that if
you social distance for 14 days remember
that was the initial 14 15 days to stop
the spread then you're gonna get this
huge number of total infections they're
gonna get 128 million total infections
between January and October and that's
really high and you got to flatten the
curve and this could overwhelm hospitals
so what you need to do instead is social
distance for two months that's what
people are calling for now you know
Trump was initially saying we want to be
open by Easter then all of a sudden it
was we want to be open by April 30th now
who knows why they're gonna be May's are
gonna be June we just don't know the
left is pushing for this to go longer
and longer because every day goes on it
reduces Trump's chances of being
reelected so Nicholas Kristof publishes
this other model which shows this much
lower lower number of infections 14
million total infections between January
and October it looks almost entirely
flat except the the authors of this
piece noticed one strange thing at the
very end of the graph the number ticks
up and you can't tell quite how much it
takes up it sort of looks like it's
ticking up exponentially but you can't
quite tell me as the graph cuts off at
October what they don't show you and
what the with the authors of this piece
which I encourage you to read a call to
honesty and pandemic modeling but they
show you is if you extend the very same
model out just another two months then
you get the exact same curve as you got
the first time all you've done is delay
how long it will be before the people
get infected but the same number of
people are gonna get infected it's not
going to change at all but that's the
kind of dishonesty we're talking about
cuz if you were just looking at these
graphs that the New York Times was
talking about then you'd say oh well
that that's really big and that number
is really big and that that's that graph
is really big and this one is small so
let's go for the small one
but they don't tell you that when you
flatten the curve or delay the curve or
whatever you're still going to get the
same number of infections very dishonest
stuff it's why you have to take these
things with some skepticism meanwhile
we're being told by left-wing
politicians we're being told by some
more neurotic people on the right we're
being told that you if you ever if you
dare question what the experts are
saying that you're basically responsible
for people being killed you've got blood
on your hands you're not taking this
seriously no we're taking it much more
seriously than people on the other
extremes right we're the ones who are
we're not taking an extreme position
here we're saying hold on let's take a
look for maybe let's extend that graph
out a little bit further are you really
you're really saying we're going to
avoid I don't think so very dishonest
models now that's just what's going on
in the news media I'm sorry to say that
other sectors of our society are taking
advantage of this pandemic my favorite
one is in the realm of criminal justice
so the Democratic mayor Sylvester Turner
democratic mayor of Houston is he's got
a message for criminals there have been
a lot of proposals during this whole
shutdown to let people out of prisons
to stop arresting people for crimes to
just reduce the jail population the the
argument being that if you reduce the
jail population then it'll be easier or
it'll be more difficult for coronavirus
to spread within the jails not not sure
that's totally true I mean jails you
can't totally socially distance in jails
right not everybody is going to be 20
feet apart in their own private
apartment so regardless they're they're
suggesting we release all these
prisoners and so how we're gonna deal
with it when all these
criminals are out on the street during
the pandemic Sylvester Turner has a
solution he just wants those criminals
to chill let me just make my plea until
the corona virus is resolved criminals
take a break
okay stay home okay
stay home and don't commit any crimes
and that way they are stay safe and out
of jail and police officers will stay
safe and can go home to their families
okay so everybody chill crooks criminals
you chill wait till the corona virus is
over okay man why didn't I think of that
oh it's so it's so obvious now in
retrospect the way that we can get
criminals to stop committing crimes is
we can just ask them to chill and like
be really nice and just say like hey can
you not commit crimes criminals I that
would be great if you wouldn't Thanks
thank you chill I get well I don't know
why we never thought of that one I'm
picking on this guy because he had this
funny press conference mayor's all over
the country doing the same thing they're
saying we got to reduce prisoners we got
to let them out I mean at least this guy
is the the kind of honesty to come out
and say yeah that our only other plan is
to say hey criminals please don't please
don't commit crimes New York did him one
better okay New York a town in New York
didn't one much better than that that
town is letting child molesters out of
prison because somehow letting child
molesters out of prison during a
shutdown in a pandemic is going to help
stop the spread of the virus or
something but generally sexual
assailants are not good at reducing the
spread of disease that's not what they
were that's not their Forte but that's
what this town decided to do part of a
statewide effort in New York 50
prisoners including child sex offenders
were released in Monroe County due to
coronavirus concerns
whatever that means even though it's
completely unclear by the way if this
jail had any confirmed cases of
coronavirus here's the here's the
headline eight registered sex offenders
have been released from Monroe County
Jail as part of a statewide
order coming from the Department of
Corrections and Community Services among
the inmates known to be staying at the
Holiday and Express that they the jail
just dumped all these guys off at our
for registered sex offenders three of
whom are registered as level 3 sex
offenders and are deemed by New York
courts as the most likely to Rhea fend
them is criminals not just burglars not
just arsonists not just a assailants not
even just rapists but child rapists and
not only child rapists the child rapists
most likely to Rhea fend her to
understand all three of the level three
sex offender staying at the Holiday Inn
Express have been convicted for the rape
of minors every single one of them hard
to understand what people are thinking
here they're they're not thinking about
how to stop the spread of coronavirus
obviously releasing dangerous child
rapists has nothing to do with stopping
the spread of coronavirus and this is
really the most egregious example of a
disturbing general trend in the whole
coronavirus ordeal which is the
lawlessness of the pandemic these people
are behaving lawlessly politicians are
doing or are using this pandemic as an
excuse to do whatever they want even if
what they want will exacerbate the
crisis I mean you saw this especially in
that coronavirus relief package from
Washington which is where at the very
last minute Nancy Pelosi and Democratic
lawmakers shoved in a bunch of green New
Deal proposals in tide coronavirus
funding to reducing airline emissions
the the wuhan flu has nothing to do with
airline emissions yet they're using this
to push their own agendas they're using
it to let people out of prison because
the left doesn't like prisons because
the left doesn't like justice so the
left doesn't want to lock people up
you've seen a number of even blue
checkmarks all over Twitter who are
left-wing people saying we need to empty
out the prisons they're doing it all in
the name of public health so that you
don't question them because if you
question the public health
advocates and supporters and experts
well then you're compromising public
health now if the New York and Houston
criminal justice strategies are suspect
they are out done only by the spiritual
strategies of some preachers who are
simply commanding the virus to go away
I bring you ladies and gentlemen the
prosperity preacher we got it yes we did
it now in mr. Copeland's defense I will
say that if that performance is not
enough to scare coronavirus away I do
not know what is it was a fiery
performance and he's not the only one
doing this there are other other
preachers who are making this point this
kind of thing is particularly seductive
during times of great trial and crisis
but ultimately it's just total spiritual
poison so we'll get to why that is in a
moment then we'll get of course to
president Trump's latest ratings busting
press briefing which and this one this
one even featured Jim Acosta so you know
mm-hmm but first if you haven't had a
chance to see some of our new content
called all-access live you should head
on over to daily wire com check it out
we will continue all of this week at 8
p.m. Eastern 5 p.m. Pacific
it's been a lot of fun I don't even
consider it a show you just kind of turn
the camera on we hang out we know that
we're all going crazy these days friends
of mine have been suggesting we do zoom
happy hours or zoom dinner or Skype this
or Facebook FaceTime that rather so I
like to think that we were kind of the
originators of this trend with our
all-access show the show is intended for
our all acts
members but you know in times of
isolation we want to open it up to all
of our members so head on over if you're
around at 8 p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m.
Pacific tonight check it out at Daly
wire.com head on over there right now
anyway Daly wire.com / subscribe we've
got a lot more
so Kenneth Copeland and others are
commanding the virus to go away their
commanding a vaccine to come around and
most Christians will find this sort of
thing fairly foreign you know this is
not how Christianity works
you don't just command a physical
well-being and then it immediately
happens you're not just you know
according to this theology which is
called prosperity theology you're you're
not just building up treasure in heaven
here in your in your spiritual life
you're also building up like literal
physical treasure in the here and now
which is rather contrary to more
traditional understandings of
Christianity but Copeland you know is is
pushing this he's a one of the great
examples of the prosperity theology
which is entertaining very often but it
is spiritually very misguided and he
doesn't just declare that there's going
to be a vaccine a Copeland is now also
declaring that America finally is
officially healed of coronavirus you
will destroy through covet 19 No More
and the United States of America is he
you and well again well that's a relief
it's sure a load off my mind my favorite
part of the whole clip is the Ed McMahon
guy on the side whoever the sidekick is
just like yes amen yeah okay sure yeah
you bet
all right okay let's do it and Copeland
obviously is leading the show there's no
need to wait until April 30th now
there's no need to wait until June 10th
in some places because America's
officially healed I don't only want to
pick on mr. Copeland Copeland is not the
only one claiming a religious shortcut
through the epidemic there's another
preacher II W Jackson who says that he
cannot
coronavirus because he talked to God
about it all right simple enough you
just that's how you know you're not
gonna get it there's no way to get it
this theology is very corrosive I you
know I hate picking on people who even
vaguely profess a faith in God because
we're in such an atheistic culture that
I kind of want to bring everybody in
gonna want to rally the troops but this
particular theology prosperity theology
is really poisonous I don't want to say
that all the prosperity people have bad
intentions some of them might have
perfectly fine intentions but you know
what they say about the road to hell and
good intentions it's just very very
wrong you know we we see in acts in
Romans in 2nd Corinthians in Colossians
and letter to the Hebrews on and on we
see the Apostle and the Apostles talking
about how they rejoice in their
sufferings in how they will have
sufferings how they have had many
sufferings and how they're so joyful
because of their sufferings because
those sufferings unite them in a way to
Christ on the cross the st. Paul says he
he rejoices in his afflictions to make
up that which is lacking in the cross
cross of Christ for the sake of his
church you know that that is a much more
traditional understanding of the role of
suffering and prosperity in Christianity
in Matthew Christ says if anyone would
come after me let him deny himself and
take up his cross and follow me for
whoever would save his life will lose it
and whoever will lose his life for my
sake will find it all right that's
that's totally the opposite of the
prosperity theology so that the
prosperity theology is on one hand anti
scriptural but the reason I'm picking on
it now well a lot of people are
suffering and there are millions and
millions of people at work and suicides
are increasing and drug addiction is
increasing and we're in this economic
devastation even if people are not in a
viral devastation is on a very practical
level this theology is is very
discouraging during times of trial
because at a very basic level what the
theology says is that your muscle your
material prosperity is tied to your
faith so if you have a lot of faith then
you can expect material prosperity and
therefore if you don't have a lot of
material prosperity what does that say
about your faith I guess you just didn't
believe hard enough I guess you just
didn't pray good enough you you just you
just don't have enough faith and that's
why you're suffering that is not at all
the message of the gospel that is not at
all the example of Christ or the
Apostles and so in periods like this
when everybody is losing their wealth
when everybody is losing their job when
everybody's is losing a home people are
losing their family members right to
hear that sort of thing
it is really spiritually discouraging in
it and it really really can hollow out
people's faith it can it can really
steal people's faith from them so
perfectly fine to enjoy the
entertainment of these clips going
around Twitter but I certainly would not
would not take them seriously
now the only thing more entertaining
than commanding the virus simply to go
away and commanding declaring that all
of America is completely healed the only
thing more entertaining than that of
course are Trump's daily press briefings
which are just phenomenal they are the
best thing on TV that's why the ratings
are higher than pretty much anything
else on TV president Trump came out you
have another good one yesterday the
there there were a few important updates
in this and but more of it is the the
media reaction because they they really
showed their hand even even more clearly
than usual so president Trump opens up
and he's talking about the current
strategy of extending this you know
through the end of April or perhaps even
further and what President Trump is
touting here looking on the bright side
is that yes we may have to shut down a
little bit longer but that strategy
could save us 1 million lives announced
we would be extending our social
distance guidelines through the end of
April this is based on modeling that
shows the peak in fatalities will not
arrive for another two weeks the same
modeling also shows that by very
vigorously following these guidelines we
could save more than 1 million American
lives think of that 1 million American
lives notice the focus there on 1
million notice the brings up its 1
million lives I repeat myself 1 million
lives this confirms the strategy that I
mentioned yesterday Trump is now using
the presses own scare numbers against
them Trump is now using the presses on
scare numbers as a defense against their
attacks because they're backing him into
this impossible corner on Sunday he
mentioned that 2.2 million Americans
could die from the virus if they don't
act quickly now the number is 1 million
Americans could be saved why the
discrepancy the discrepancy there is to
give himself some breathing room and to
reset expectations here so too 2.2
million Americans could have died now
we're saying we're going to save like
what happens to the 1.2 million
Americans in the middle what the press
wants to do is use the scare numbers to
shut down the economy 2.2 million but
then once the economy's shut down every
single death every hospitalization every
sniffle is going to be used as evidence
that Trump is some callous monster and
nobody should have died at all the real
numbers should have been zero now of
course we know that's not how it works
we know that 37,000 and in many cases
tens of thousands of more people die
each year from the flu we know that
38,000 people die each year from car
accidents we know that 70,000 people die
each year from drug overdoses right
these huge numbers that media doesn't
talk about numbers actually which might
get worse because of this shutdown and
yet we're so uncomfortable with the
concept of death especially natural
death that we don't want to acknowledge
it so now every single person who dies
is evidence that Trump did something
wrong but of course that's not evidence
of that pee
we'll die you know the fact that 35,000
people die from the flu is not evidence
that the government screwed something up
natural death occurs mortality is real
no one here gets out alive not from this
particular world anyway and yet the
press is banking on the fact that that
we won't pay attention to that so Trump
is resetting expectations here I think
it's very smart
because right now the more reliable
projections that would seem suggest that
it's not going to be 2 million people
who die it's not going to be 1 million
people who die it's going to be closer
to I don't know 100,000 look it's a
horrible number nobody wants a hundred
thousand people to die but it's
certainly a much better situation than a
million or two million people dying and
when you compare it even to drug
overdoses per year it's not all that
much more you know it's death is a very
sad thing Trump says later on in this
press conference a lot of very sad
things happen in this country and in
this world then President Trump calls up
his friends from corporate America and
introduces them and halves them give a
couple words the media are furious about
this they don't like it when he brings
up his friends from the business
community but the strategy is brilliant
and there's a lot of evidence that it's
working joining us this afternoon are
CEOs of the great American companies
that are fulfilling their patriotic duty
by producing or donating medical
equipment to help meet our most urgent
needs what they're doing is incredible
and these are great companies Darius Dom
Scheck of Honeywell you know that and
Darius has been somebody that I've dealt
with in the past and he's a great leader
of a great company
Deborah Waller of jockey International a
friend of mine Mike lyndale of my pillow
boy do you sell those pillows that's
unbelievable what you do David Taylor of
Procter & Gamble and Greg Hayes of
United Technologies Corporation and I
just want to tell all of you that
America is very grateful to you and what
you've done an amazing job you've done
and we thank you very much okay why does
he do this why does he go on this
interlude you know he even goes on heaps
some more praise on these business
guys the left wingers are ragging on
Trump for bringing them up there they
only want to hear from doctors maybe
they'll they'll settle for hearing from
Trump and some of his appointees but
really the left just wants to hear from
the public health dictators but it is
tactically brilliant to have these
business leaders up there because it
creates a powerful incentive for them to
help out the country during this time of
crisis now I suspect many of them would
help out anyway but if you know that the
president of United States is going to
bring you up there on international
television and say hey thanks so much
CEO of Honeywell for all the good that
you're doing that is going to help out
the company that's going to give
Americans more confidence in your
company that's going to give Americans
and people around the world more
affection for your company and it's not
just some kind of cheap PR stunt they're
actually doing the work these companies
are actually going out and helping
people in producing medical equipment
that we need urgently at hospitals so
it's a smart thing to do yeah I think
it's the right thing to do it shows
genuine gratitude and it creates an
incentive for more businesses to help
out now if that if the media weren't mad
enough about Trump bringing up generally
business leaders to come speak you can
only imagine what they did what they
said how they reacted when the CEO of my
pillow
Mike Lendl got up there to speak CNN was
so furious they actually cut away from
it even though these press briefings are
getting better ratings than anything
else on television right now even though
the press briefings are giving you
actual urgent news that moves markets
and moves the way that we react in terms
of public health they cut away because
they hate the my pillow guy so much that
they couldn't watch it
here's Wolf Blitzer
okay well my pillow is on aus vertically
integrated company which has been forced
to adjust to the changing business part
we're gonna continue to monitor the
White House briefing and gets the latest
information the president they couldn't
stand it
Oliver Darcy on CNN cut rather referred
to CNN cutting away from Michael in
Delhi tweets that quote CNN cuts away
from the White House run of iris
briefing when Trump invites the my
pillow guy up to the podium to talk they
always refer to him as the my pillow guy
that's the only way the never Mike
lyndale not CEO not the founder nope
just a my pillow guy Jamie O'Grady
writer for the New York Times are you
effing kidding me then all caps he has
the my pillow guy on to sell his garbage
product during a pandemic briefing three
question marks three exclamation points
by the way I've heard my pillow is like
a really nice pillow so I don't think
it's a garbage product i think is pretty
popular product
NBC's david girl fun fact if the my
pillow guy Michael and Dell appears in a
briefing it is no longer a briefing well
you know it's too bad they didn't listen
to it because if they had listened to
him and what he had to say
they'd have learned that Michael in Dell
is doing more to help the country out
during this pandemic then all of them
combined
everyone at CNN all the blue checkmarks
on Twitter this guy is doing more than
all of them my pillow is a u.s.
vertically integrated company which has
been forced to adjust to the changing
business environment as a result of a
pandemic my pill is uniquely position is
a US company that functions as a
manufacturer logistics management
distribute and direct to consumer given
our current business lines we are
experienced the effects of this pandemic
firsthand but my pill is done with the
established and internal Task Force
which is monitoring future needs of
companies across the country as a result
of this pandemic and given our position
we've begun to research and develop new
protocols to address the current and
future needs of US businesses across
multiple sectors how companies are going
to prepare themselves when they once
again open up in and changes to their
current operations in order to adjust to
future threats and pandemic
my pill has designated some of his call
center to help us companies navigate the
many issues that resulted from this
pandemic
we've debt we've dedicated 75% of my
manufacturing to produce cotton face
masks I'm up to time in three days I was
up to 10,000 a day by Friday I want to
be up to 50,000 a day I'm proud to
manufacture our products in the United
States and I'm even more proud to be
able to serve our nation in this great
time of need 50,000 face masks a day the
guys turned over 75% of his production
to making face masks that's pretty good
stuff first of all that's useful
information that's good to know that a
company can pivot like that it's useful
information that his products are made
in America now that we're trying to move
our supply chain out of other countries
and it's useful to know that we've got
just one guy just one guy with one
company making 50,000 face masks a day
but the reason that left-wing
journalists hate mic Lindale is not just
because they don't like pillows I'm sure
they like pillows just fine it's not
even just that lyndale is a conservative
and likes Donald Trump though certainly
that's a big part of it the ultimate
reason is that Mike Lynn Dell is
unabashed about his devotion to Christ
is he is totally open and evangelical in
his Christianity now I wrote something
off the cuff if I can read it
God gave us grace on November 8 2016 to
change the course we were on God had
been taken out of our schools and lives
a nation had turned his back on God and
I encourage you use this time at home to
get back to home to get back in the word
read our Bibles and spend time with our
families our president gave us so much
hope we're just a few short months ago
we had the best economy the lowest
unemployment and wages going up it was
amazing with our great president vice
president and this administration and
all the great people in this country
praying daily we will get through this
and get back to a place that's stronger
and safer than ever what a great message
that is okay and Lyndell is a pretty
inspiring guy what most people don't
know about him is he's a former crack
addict this guy had huge drug problem
his life was in complete shambles and
then he he got his life together one
imagines through the grace of God and is
one of the most successful guys in the
country and he's giving press briefings
with the president he's helping out his
fellow Americans and making a lot of
face masks that's a wonderful thing you
know compare this to the prosperity
theology that we were just listening to
well Michael and Della's not saying I
had so much faith and that's why we got
a great stock market and the economy he
was great and I got all this money no he
was saying actually the opposite he was
like man well in his personal story his
life was in shambles and then he was
saved by Amazing Race
and when it comes to the economy was
like God gave us grace in 2016 we you
know he is tying it in with what has
happened politically or economically but
he's not saying it's cuz like we finally
had enough faith and so God rewarded us
no no God gave us grace he gave us mercy
he and he will have mercy on us still
and we've got to do our part and live
live our faith and the the fruit of that
faith so a really really nice message
obviously CNN CNN didn't hear that
message they have to close their ears
and say la la la whenever anybody
mentions any sort of political or heaven
forfend religious truth then of course
too close at the conference there was
the obligatory Trump smackdown of CNN
this time spurred by no less than CNN's
very own Ron Burgundy Jim Acosta himself
what do you say to Americans who are
upset with you over the way you
downplayed this crisis over the last
couple of months we have it very much
under control in this country the corona
virus is very much under control in the
USA it's going to disappear it's like a
miracle it will disappear March 4th
we have a very small number of people in
this country infected March 10th we're
prepared we're doing a great job with it
it will go away just a calm it will go
away what do you say to Americans we'll
leave that you got this wrong and I do
want them to stay calm and we are doing
a great job if you look at those
individual statements they're all true
stay calm it will go away you know it
you know it is going away and it will go
away and we're going to have a great
victory
and it's people like you and CNN that
say things like that that it's why
people just don't want to listen to CN
anymore you could ask a normal question
the statements I made or I want to keep
the country calm
I don't want panic in the country I
could cause panic much better than even
you I could do much I would make you
look like a minor league player but you
know what I don't want to do that I want
to have our country become and strong
and fight and win and it will go away I
love that comment he says there I mean I
love the Smackdown of Jim Acosta is
always hilarious but I love that comment
at the end he goes you know instead of
asking a nasty question instead of
trying to spread panic look I could
spread panic I could spread panic a
whole lot better than you but I'm not
doing that you know we have the power to
do this at our fingertips we've got or
social media accounts we talked to
friends and family we go on FaceTime and
Skype and all right we have the ability
either to keep a cool head
be rational taking all the information
not panic not lose our minds not scream
and wail and rend our garments or we can
do that or we can generate panic the the
choice is ours but a trump is saying
look I'm not going to do that I'm gonna
try to help the country out and Jim
Acosta is saying rah rah I don't know
that's my impression of Jim Acosta
look at me look at me I'm Jim Acosta as
as Andrew Clavin says you know those are
the two choices and that's a choice that
not just the mainstream media have to
make but that each each of us can make
as well don't forget as we're trying to
stop the spread of the virus that only
you can stop the spread of fake news all
right that is our show come back
tomorrow I'm sure we'll have a whole lot
more
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski
editor and associate producer danny
D'Amico audio mixer robin Fenderson hair
and makeup nikka geneva production
assistant ryan love the michael knowles
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]